[Music]
thanks for joining us America we're glad
you're here this is the Dave Ramsey show
the phone number here is triple 8 8 2 5
5 2 2 5 so Kelly and I were talking at
the break we have a generation of people
who no longer speak on the telephone
they only text and so I'm going to give
you a little telephone instruction for
those of you that use a cell phone to
actually speak into it number one you
have to speak into it you can't lay it
on your shoulder on your chest or put it
on speakerphone if you're on a talk
radio show on this talk radio show in
the future when you do that I will
simply put you on hold and go to the
next caller because our listeners are in
their car they can't understand your
muffled but because you're talking
sideways towards your phone not into
your phone the second thing is you have
to stand still you're on a digital
device and digital devices are either
connected or not connected and when you
walk around pace go into the bathroom
try to feed the kids and everything else
while you're on the phone with me and 15
million people we get this muffled come
and go sound and we can't understand you
and if I can't understand you you're not
a good caller and a good caller is on
hold I'm a bad caller is on hold because
we're here to help you and we don't mind
helping you but I'm not gonna fight
through this stuff anymore so you guys
don't have to learn to talk on a phone I
know it's a new thing for you text
generation but we will we will work on
it with you and we will get you there
one more skill that you get from the
Dave Ramsey show here
seriously it's 15 million people listen
to you going and nobody wants to listen
that crap and I can't understand what
you're saying anyway I just had three
kids nobody wants to listen to that so
stand still and talk directly into your
phone this is not rocket science Kelly
tells you this 14 times before we pick
up and then you still do it so I'm gonna
put you on hold from this point for it
I'll be kind to you but I'm not going to
talk to you